now without actually doing the whole
expansion okay for a quartic what could
we say accordingly we're going to take
the same pattern like make the leading
coefficient age so I've got a X to the
fourth plus B X cubed plus CX squared
all the way down to here okay so here's
a general quartic right it has five
coefficients in here it should have how
many roots five right so I use alpha
beta and gamma before now I'm going to
add back in I showed you this before I
was counting four I said five anyway so
before it's right so what are my
relationships going to be when I add
them all up think about this way I'm
going to write this first step here but
I'm not going to do any of the expansion
I'll see if you could follow the
argument right if this thing should be
equivalent to eight times that's put the
four it's in here so this is the four
linear factors that I should be getting
if there are four roots again think
about for instance how am I going to get
an alpha up here - yeah right
well if I get that alpha it's gonna
multiply by X X X right so you gotta get
next cube so I'm comparing to this guy
right to get a better there's a bit of
there and again you have to choose the
MTU and Xfinity again you're getting
your necks cubed again you're comparing
to this B coefficient right whatever the
second one was okay so therefore without
any actual algebraic expansion let's
write out the ritzy coefficients those
results for a quick it's not hard to
follow the pattern you do the sub one at
a time and it's still amazingly -
b.length you do the sub 2 at I know this
is a bit trickier okay we're going down
to one four six four one so this is an
extra possible triangle right I've
already got this this is the form that's
here that's for c1 now I'm doing for c2
site should expect
terms that's how I know I would have
missed in it okay help me out al Kabeer
I do I tend to do all the alphas first
salga alpha beta alpha gamma Alpha Delta
okay then I do all the beaters next I've
already done alphabet on so I'll do
beaded gamma and mean uh Delta now look
number 5 Pascal's triangle tells me I'm
only to see one more which is the Gamma
Delta the very last pair right another
way Gamma Delta another way that I could
know is you look at how many times
you've used each of the roots okay how
many times have I used alpha lately one
two three times right you can only use
it three times because it really has
three other things to pair up with how
many times you use beat up one two three
times because there are only three other
things to compare it with have u times u
gamma on 1 2 3 and you can see I don't
need to do Delta for you gee I've got 3
as well okay now again the coefficients
are going to go to the next one and the
sign is going to all today now we do
them three times how many terms am I
going to expect four of them because
I've got the next one Pascal's triangle
some Bittaker this is bit harder Alpha
Beta Gamma I do all the alphas but yeah
Alpha Beta Delta I can't really missing
two more so I know I could do a Beta
Gamma Delta and I'd be c1 last one Alpha
Gamma Delta perfect great again I can
check how many times do I use alpha one
two three times how many times if I use
beat up one two three typing even do
this like you can see and the sign
alternates and you go to the next
coefficient
mercifully the last one is easy to to
this sum up sign the sulphur at a time
Alpha Beta Gamma Delta and it's the sign
alternates and you go to the next
done they are the results for the clinic
you can use Eddie you can use any letter
you like however this is the letter that
gets traditionally used and like I mean
I think it's worth money because you
will see yeah you don't have to use
yeah- you're talking about this oh yes
oh yeah of course it is yeah my sign
alternate okay great it was that